call me dude Z and then you've got you
know people doing cat [__] with their
hands in these little paw things Judy
Dench exposes her cat vagina in one
scene I'm sorry what was that I've seen
this movie four times it's when Ian
you've seen it four times well I've seen
it every Christmas I might have seen it
a few more
Jesus four times
this is the [__] cough genius not a
cat's genius cough genius I watched that
movie the week it came out I would say
probably 20 times
not I went to the [__] Arc Light with
a notebook that I bought specifically
for the purpose of taking notes during
every scene by myself I'm sitting there
in the dark just
scribbling away people are looking at me
on either side like what the [__] is
this Maniac doing probably fearing for
their lives
um that movie needs to be studied and so
I studied it let me tell you
foreign